how are you doing today sir i'm good
baby how are you oh i called you baby
like
um i'm doing very well that was not what
i expected to be called
seriously congrats on this movie uh you
and jessica are fantastic um and uh i
have a lot of questions about that but
because i have so much time with you
there's a bunch of things we're going to
talk about hopefully
you enjoy the questions as i prepped uh
so i want to start with what tv series
would you love to guest star on
search party what movie or movies uh
have you seen the most the goonies
um
teen wolf
um
back to the future ghostbusters one and
two
indiana jones temple of doom
i mean
drug versus a volcano
oh a little unorthodox choice clean
slate
got it okay you do you know clean slate
i don't think i i actually you know i've
seen a lot of movies and i don't know if
i know clean slate it's a little known
dana carvey
um
he played
like the original memento but it's a
comedy
right i do i do actually know this movie
yes amnesia and he wakes up every
morning he's forgotten everything he's
learned from the case from the from the
day before he's like a detective with
amnesia i haven't seen it in forever i
think i only saw it once but i know i
know the film um
jumping into something else um when
you're filming a movie how can you leave
the character you're playing on set or
does a piece of it always come home with
you every night during the shoot
i can choose i decide
sometimes it's useful
to keep it with me and other times it's
very it's important to leave it for
instance when i was doing the social
network we were shooting
the scene where i come
to palo alto and i'm covered in drenched
in rain and justin's character sean
parker answers the door and i'm very
surprised to see him i'm not all that
happy to see him
and you know i come in and me and jesse
have our kind of tiff we got halfway
through that that scene on a friday and
we hadn't done my coverage yet
and i had the weekend
um to stew and i just decided to stay in
it that may not have been a good
decision because i went to a couple of
like it was like the golden globes that
weekend or something so i went to like
some golden globe pre golden globe
parties or something and i think i got
into an altercation
with a couple of people that i shouldn't
have got into an altercation with
and i'm not gonna name names but it's uh
for a private story sometime i'll tell
you
um the social network is what i call a
masterpiece when you think back on the
making of that film and working with
fincher uh besides this story what's the
first thing that comes to your mind
jesse
laptop smash that day
that long goddamn day
and and fincher
being such a good dad that day he was
like the perfect
sports dad he was like
in instilling me with
keep doing it and you can keep doing it
believe that you can keep doing i know
i'm going to ask you to do this a lot
and your voice is going to be tired and
your heart's going to be tired and your
body's going to be exhausted and you're
going to hate me and that's okay because
we are going to get it absolutely
perfect
and then at the end instead of saying
we're moving on i'm i was sat on the
floor after take
35 40 of of that of my close-up of that
scene which you can imagine would have
been a lot of
screaming and kind of agony and i'm sat
on the floor just kind of wiped
exhausted thinking we're probably going
to go again another 10 times he just
kind of walks up to me up that corridor
from his monitor and he
kind of puts his hand out to me and
pulls me up and and shakes my hand and
he says
moving on and that was that so that so
that was a beautiful moment i felt very
very um kind of uh gratified like living
at all the field that was a beautiful
day i loved it
in the years since the film have you
talked to eduardo
no no i i wonder if i ever will i would
i'm i'm open i'm very very open for that
conversation i would love to have a hang
on uh one of the things about fincher in
all of his movies is that he gets
amazing performances out of everyone and
every director that i've ever spoken
with has a different way of working on
set fincher obviously has a very unique
way of working working on set what is
his secret because it's not just about
the takes it's about him being an
amazing director so what what is it that
gets these amazing performances out of
everyone
i think a lot of it is
getting the act that what one of the
things i understand about why he does
that amount of takes is that he's
getting
he's getting the actor so that he
forgets the act so the actor he or she
forgets
they're being filmed
um
so that that's a part of
the
the kind of the magic of
the performances in each of his films i
think he's looking for that moment where
you forget you're there you forget
what's happening and there's a purity
and a vulnerability and openness
and the audience responds to that in a
deeply unconscious way um suddenly
you're there's no acting there's no
performing it's just
pure and i think that's a part of what
he's looking for and also he's very
precise he can he can see it
and he and i think that he said this
before i don't think i'm misquoting him
it's like being a catcher in in in a
baseball game
he doesn't know
why it works but when
when the pitch hits the glove just so
he can feel it he's like okay we got it
moving on so
he just has an instinctive trust and you
know the the best directors i've ever
worked with have that mel mel gibson's
that way scorsese's that way
um you know a bunch of other directors
i've worked with it that way mike
nichols you know it's it's
it's an instinctive
oh that was it got it done there's not a
it's a body like
gut kind of intuition what was cooler
for you uh being on an episode of doctor
who or hosting snl
i'm not i don't want to compare things
um but i will say
that just for me personally
i'm much
i wasn't a big doctor who fan to be
honest i loved doing it i loved working
with all the people on it but i have to
say like my
history is much more an snl
my father was a big snl fan and so i i
felt much more like
that had lived in my imagination
you've done a lot of stage work and i
can't imagine if you're like the
nervousness that might go on before you
step on stage did that help you when
you're getting ready to come out on
stage on snl or are you still [ __ ]
bricks when you're about to walk out
from behind the door to 11 30 at night
on a saturday oh no it's every time no
no yeah it's every time every time no
matter what it is snl or theater or a
film set like it doesn't like there's
always that
kind of like you're in the you're like a
a horse in the in the starting blocks
and you're just like why isn't the cage
opening and am i gonna die when the cage
opens like no i
every time before i go on stage or do
any kind of performance there is a
threshold to cross for me internally
which is am i going to die if i go out
there i think i might die
hmm
do i risk it because like i haven't died
yet but maybe the today's the day that i
die but snl was was
specifically intense for for all the
reasons you can imagine but like yeah
you're in this back you're in this box
at the back there's not space back there
you get brought into this box and those
doors open
and um and i remember i think i was just
dancing and i was just like kind of
thrashing and just like making sure that
i wasn't getting like stiff and tight in
my body and i was just kind of like
i let the energy just kind of kind of
leave me like go through me and used it
as best i could but yeah it was i've
never watched snl the snl that i did i
never intend to because it was just the
most pure experience i don't want it to
be ruined by watching my work in it
because it wasn't it was just like the
experience is the thing and being
actually like the great thing is like
being a part of the um
the the crew and the company and
supporting them in
their brilliance like i think that's
like how i if if i ever do it again that
that's the intention it's like you know
i just want to be here to help you guys
shine that's like kind of like the
awesome part of it you have managed to
land such incredible roles through your
already amazing career
is there a role though that you went
after that you didn't get that still
stings
no
actually no i mean that there's there's
stuff that
is kind of the opposite that there's
there's stuff that i was
offered
that i said no to and again but i don't
regret it i don't there's nothing i
regret it was absolutely right
and uh
no i i really have this weird kind of
wacky belief that everything is
perfect everything happens for for a
reason so no i i don't i don't um no
actually no no
you got to work with philip seymour
hoffman and mike nichols on broadway and
i am curious and it's been it's been
something on my mind since you worked
with them how much did you actually pay
to be in the production to work with
them because it that's insane
yeah it was it was the best
one of the greatest times of my life
creatively spiritually life-wise i just
finished
shooting the first spider-man film and
um
i i needed i needed it i actually needed
it for my my soul like theater is my
home always will be my home my first
kind of creative spiritual home i
suppose
and to do but but then to do an arthur
to do arthur miller and to do that
particular play
and then you know you you you put phil
as willie loman and then mike
directly i mean what
what what you know it does it doesn't
bear
there's no way of being able to
comprehend the
the kind of the the perfect perfection
and beauty of that experience like it's
i'm so grateful for it what do you think
might surprise people to learn
about being part of a big broadway
production like that
your dressing rooms are pretty shitty
for the most part
um
that that that maybe
um uh
i i don't i don't know if there's
anything i could say that would be
surprising it's it's it's just a just a
great it's just so soulful it just feels
so right for me
um
there's also a nice thing that happens
in broadway where everyone who's doing a
show at the same time
gets to know each other there's a
community that you actually feel a part
of which is a rare thing in what we do
and everyone is you know supportive of
each other's shows and it's so that was
a surprising thing for me because you
don't get that as much in london because
it's all a bit more spread out the
theaters are a bit more spread out
whereas in broadway you're all neighbors
on a nightly basis and you're seeing
each other in
restaurants late at night afterwards and
or bars and asking how how tonight's
show went and who was in and
what you [ __ ] up and what you got
right and
yeah there's a real kind of community
feeling
uh you did amazing work with angels in
america and i know that every night it
had to take really take a toll on you at
any point before you at any point during
the run in london or on broadway we were
like i can't do this anymore this is
really killing me
yeah a few times yeah yeah a bunch of
times um
yeah and i know it's only a play and you
know it's not real life but your body
doesn't know that because if you're if
you're doing it for the way the way that
i work is
you know you're attempting to live it as
much as you possibly can living under
those circumstances and those imagined
circumstances that the character is
going through so your body
is creating you know chemicals and
adrenaline and
um
pain and woundedness and joy and you
know you're
in love and you're losing your lover and
you're dying and you're visiting heaven
so like you're losing your mind like
especially in that play the character
prior that i played goes through he just
he goes through the whole human
experience in eight hours
of um of life death and then life again
and like being faced with a choice
between life and death and choosing to
live you know i mean it doesn't get more
profound than that or more agonizing and
suffering than that
um so so yeah there were nights where i
was like [ __ ] this why am i doing this
to myself and those were the nights that
were the best performances probably
because there was something else that
had to come in because i did i knew that
i couldn't do it with sheer will and
drive and force i knew i needed to
to lean back
on
something else something some unseen
call it god call it my own higher power
call it the universe call it the theater
gods like i needed help to get through
and
and it's weird the more you let go
the more the the freer you are and the
more the thing just happens so i mean
those are those nights were the most
special ones because you felt like you
were
being kind of carried on some kind of
wind in in and yeah it's beautiful you
obviously made two spider-man movies
with mark webb i don't think anyone can
prepare you for being in films of that
scope and scale and what they mean to a
studio and the marketing and everything
do you miss being in those sort of films
because or are you sort of like i'm glad
i experienced it and those are kind of
scary i mean i feel a lot of ways about
it like i'm really glad i did it like
there's no not one part of me that that
regrets it at all like i feel so
grateful for all the friendships and
relationships i built and
and the experience like the expect
i got to have that experience of being a
part of that kind of beyond
kind of thing
um and playing a character that has
meant the world to me since i was three
as we all know and so there was nothing
and i learned so much about myself about
how i like to work how i don't like to
work about what storytelling means to me
about what it doesn't mean to me i
learned a lot about my own relationship
to
materialism commercialization
commodification selling t-shirts and
mugs and happy meals um
that that that stuff's tricky for me i'm
not i'm not crazy about
that aspect of our culture to be honest
the con the the highly consumerist kind
of
aspects of our culture that i think
there's a lot of damage um because it
breeds a meaninglessness it for me i
think it's
there's a there's a redirect that i want
to be a part of which is back towards
things that are more
eternal and dependable because the
things that we are being kind of taught
to depend upon are just um so
undependable um so for me
and i think covert has done this for a
lot of people is it's brought people
back to actually what do i love and who
am i and where do i want to live do i
want to live by a river do i want to
live by a lake do i live in the woods
and how do i get rid of you know this
being um the the thing that that defines
who i am how i'm perceived how i
perceive myself and my value in the
world um
you know i'm being a bit glib but but
but also i i so for me
that was a really interesting
dynamic and dilemma for me so it's on
the second press tour we created me and
my
um my friend we my publicist at the time
we created this with sony we created
this splinter press tour
so that every city would go to we would
go and visit
a kind of a small local
philanthropic organization and
bring all of the energy that and
attention that we had from this
character in this story
and you know they're predominantly
wanting to sell cinema tickets but
actually there's there was a way of
redirecting it towards you know those
more kind of underdog peter parker
organizations around the world so that
that was the the kind of remedy for me
um yeah so you know it's it's a big
learning experience for sure
uh i i am curious though did you ever
talk to drew about that sinister six
movie was that like how close did that
actually get to being made with you
i don't know how close it got
but i definitely had a few meetings and
it was really exciting i've got to say
because drew i love drew so much and i
love cabin in the woods and i you know
and the other stuff that he's that he's
made
and we we just got on like a house on
fire
and i loved his vision he's so unique
and odd and like
kind of
off-kilter and
you know uh
you know not unconventional in his
creative choices so yeah that was
definitely a fun couple of months but
you know life life
no i i get it i'm a big fan of drew and
actually that was the thing that really
disappointed me when that film didn't
happen just because he's such a comic
book fan and i just was so excited about
seeing his take on these characters and
you know it would have been cool maybe
one day he'll get to do it yeah but it
would have been cool
um and by the way i agree with you with
the material things except if you look
behind me
i i think i think i i often think about
fincher's uh fight club and the the line
of the things you own end up owning you
you know it's it's just anyway that's a
whole separate thing um jumping into why
i actually get to talk to you today um
which i i i'm sure you were like we're
never getting there
what is it like actually stepping on set
or in rehearsals with jessica when you
see the level of commitment she is doing
for this role and how how passionate she
feels about playing this character yeah
it's awesome and you expect nothing less
you know it's you know just who she is
as an actor and
i um i admire a great deal i value i
value that kind of commitment and um
yeah i i
you know
i knew that would be the case
um and it was great because it means
that you can just show up in the scene
and you can really just be present with
your fellow actor and you know that that
it's going to be truthful you know that
it's going to be um
uh
alive and and honest so i and and yeah
and you know it's
she's a remarkable remarkable artist
that i got to
to witness firsthand and play with so
i'm very grateful i always love learning
about you know things about the making
of a movie that you might not have heard
what do you think might surprise people
uh to learn about the making of this
film or the research you did just you
know something you could share yeah we
would go to church every sunday me and
jess we would go to um
heritage usa um
their old uh stomping ground
me and jessica would get a coffee every
every sunday morning and we would go and
it's a different evangelical church now
there but we would go and join service
and just kind of hang out commune kind
of cringe at things that didn't make
sense to us and kind of get quite moved
about things that did
and uh kind of talked to the community
there and we got toured around and we we
would do that as a ritual together every
sunday
um
and yeah it was very very beautiful and
surprising i didn't expect to be doing
that with jess but it was a really
gorgeous thing that we got to
explore together um you know i'm there
that that that i think was was
definitely unexpected
i would imagine that you research and
prepare a lot for every role that you're
gonna do but for something like this
where you're playing i guess i'm just
curious what is the level of
you know you know you're going to film
and say september when are you actually
really digging in and focusing like
laser focusing on i'm getting ready for
this project
it depends you know with with silence i
took a year
with hacksaw rage it was probably about
three months
with this i would say probably about two
and a half to three months
um with lin-manuel's movie tic-tic boom
i had to learn how to sing i had to
learn how to play piano and i had to
embody jonathan larson so that and and
it happened just so happened that i had
a year to to do it while doing other
things so that was a year and a half it
was that was kind of on the that was
boiling for a year and a half
and then um and then the real just firm
focus was probably about four months for
that um anyway so it's different every
time and each thing requires a different
amount of
different type of study a different type
of preparation like
the thing i'm doing now this is a mini
series of under the banner of heaven up
here in calgary with dustin lance black
and you know
i i got to go to salt lake city recently
on my way out here and do some hang out
with some mormons and some ex-mormons
and some bishops
and uh some gay mormons and some uh you
know fallen mormons and some cop mormons
it was you know so that stuff and same
with 99 homes i got to go to florida and
do a week research of people who are
affected by the housing crisis and yeah
that stuff is really i just love it
uh one of the things that i don't think
uh people realize is what jim and tammy
faye did i mean they literally built a
media empire which is and back in the
70s or early 80s this is really hard to
do
you know
what what
i mean can you sort of talk about what
they accomplished before obviously their
downfall
oh it's insane like you know
jim jim was a builder like he built a
theme park he built as you say a media
empire he
he built housing for single mothers who
had been abused he had built
housing for disabled kids he
had ministries all over the world um
it's remarkable what he did um
it's insane like i have no idea
how one and of course you know
if i think as soon as you start building
in that way you're gonna you have to get
into some corrupt stuff to keep it going
and also for him his justification was
that god wants this god wants me to
create places for christians he wants me
to convert as many people as possible he
wants me to make christianity fun he
wants me to show that actual material
prosperity is what god wants he just
happened to misread the word prosperity
in the bible for material commercial
financial prosperity and comfort whereas
etymologically from the original greek
he discovered while he was in jail
spiritual prosperity is a very very
different thing to economic prosperity
and i think he started to understand
that when he was doing more study after
he went to prison the thing that i think
a lot of people forget is what tammy fay
she was on the side of supporting people
with hiv and aids and supporting gay
people and supporting marginalized
people when it was not
um you know it's a little easier now
than it was back then can you sort of
talk about that she was really um just a
really good person
yeah you know and again again you know
jessica will have a much better more
in-depth answer to this but from my what
i perceive is that
tammy was a proper christian like in the
sense of
you know give me give me your poor
you're weak you're hungry you know it's
it's
those real true jesus christ christian
values of the people who feel ostracized
and exiled and mistreated
um that those are the people who she
felt this tremendous kinship with and
connection with
and um it just so happened that of
course you know the
and
she was very camp she was camp she was
fabulous and kind of she was a drag
queen in a way you know like that's one
way of
of uh perceiving who she was with with
her makeup and with her outfits and with
her performative kind of stance and
and the joy and the fun and like
self-effacing humor and i don't know she
was she was kind of a remarkable anomaly
in that world and in the world generally
after you wrap what you're filming now
with dustin do you know what you're
gonna do
no not not right now not right now i
have um
um no it's because we're shooting until
december so it's a little bit of a ways
off
oh wow okay yeah it's all it's a mini
series isn't it yeah
yeah um i want to jump actually real
quick and talk about tick tick boom
which is a project i
cannot wait to see um i'm over i'm just
i'm very excited um
i still get sad when i think about
jonathan and dying so young and it still
bums me out um what did it mean to you
to basically play him yeah yeah i mean
the the to the best of my ability it was
yeah really profound like i i i want to
talk more in depth with you at some
point about it because i really do
feel poor very um
it's i'm really connected to the project
in a way that is is deeper than usual
and i i feel very
grateful responsibility
and joy in in that i got to attempt to
to honor him and the sacredness of his
life and the sacredness of what he was
trying to make his life about
um
and him as an artist him as a friend him
as a
boyfriend him as a son
and him as a revolutionary you know like
he was he was um not afraid of ruffling
feathers and upsetting people he was
someone that one that saw
that saw how sick the world was and how
toxic the world was and he actually
really wanted to
change it you know whether it was
about the environment or about again you
know commodification and materialism
um a kind of uh a cruelty that he was
witnessing or a kind of again like and
it was all in the backdrop of his
friends
um getting sick and in a lot of cases
dying of hiv and aids very young
um so that he had this profound
awareness of um
the kind of um
the missing the mark
of life that the culture was doing that
the the people in charge politicians and
leaders were doing especially when it
came to
you know not protecting the sanctity of
the lives of his friends
even though people know about him
there's just so much they don't know
yeah uh i am curious what i i know lynn
is obviously a huge fan of his uh you
know jonathan's work what was it like
those first few days on set when you
realized the significance of what you
were trying to bring to the screen and
did you feel that sort of pressure or do
you sort of just
so excited to be there i think i felt i
started to feel what i imagined jonath
jonathan felt in his short
and
fireworks
energetic energy of a life
because he was always at an 11 because i
think somewhere he knew he didn't have
long like tik tik boom you know it's his
heart
and you we you know for those of us who
do know he he he died of of um marfan
syndrome at 35
on the eve of the first preview of rend
off broadway and it was it was a heart
condition he had a heart attack and so
tiktik boom is
a prophetic he he knew there was a there
was a thing of like i know i don't have
a lot of time
time to get this
to get these songs out to get my song
sung as much as possible like none of us
ever will we'll sing our song fully in
this life we will all die before with an
un with a with an unfinished song we
hope we leave people behind who will
keep that song going so for me it was
like i think i woke up every morning
as the character
of
yeah pressure but it was like the tick
tick boom pressure of how do i
i've gotta how do i honor him to his
hilt how do i how do i even attempt to
reach towards who he was as a person in
all of his dimension and all of his lust
and joy for life and all of his
kind of cosmic prophetic awareness of
what the future like a kind of this this
dystopian future that he kind of
predicted and also
like
going back to the things that
our real meaning that he was trying to
wake us up to he was trying to wake up a
generation
to um
to a life of much more meaning and of
creativity and art and community and
you know all of the ethos of um bohemia
all of the ethos of um rent like that's
what he was trying to do wake us up to
life and the celebration of life and the
sanctity of life so yeah i woke up every
morning
after just a few hours sleep because he
wouldn't let me sleep with um that kind
of yearning and need to fulfill his
legacy and to keep his song being sung
that was uh the greatest gift
cannot wait to talk to you more in depth
once i have seen the movie uh i have to
wrap here and i'm just gonna say thank
you so much for giving me so much time
and uh i wish you nothing but the best
man you too do necessarily